- Many years ago, this young man said,
"Let's do a vlog."
I was like, "Okay."
This is episode 400.
What's up, vlog?
I like calling you vlog, by the way.
I'm just not romantic about
anything that happened yesterday.
90% of people default
into looking behind them
instead of looking ahead of them.
♪ There's a moment ♪
Can you understand that
you're asking to live
a top 1% life in a 7.7
billion person world?
People's fears are
predicated on other people.
Stop looking for permission.
And so, I just don't understand
why people are living
their lives like that.
Most of all, nothing's gonna happen
unless you do something, please!
If you then wrap your head around
what you're actually aspiring to do.
Like, what do you think's going on here?
(cheering)
I mean it, I take shit in a super macro.
Like, I'd much rather be me than this
fucking ugly green carpet.
I think I just wanna play
until I die, you know?
And that's why I can see
when somebody likes it,
no matter what the fuck it is.
You never get to cash
out and buy the Lambo.
The game is the fucking Lambo.
Once you love the game,
whatever that is, you win.
It's a whirlwind.
Vlog, I didn't drop it.
I'm just trying to make
it more binary for people,
which is are you happy or are you not?
And if you're not, why?
Life's about choices, brother.
Who the hell's permission
are you looking for
to do your thing?
Like, figuring yourself
out, ask that person out,
quit that fucking bullshit job.
The punchline is self-awareness, man.
I'm not gonna tell them, "Go do this."
I don't know them, I don't know you.
Do you.
You know you.
Stop being scared of who you are.
If you love it so much,
then you wouldn't be here,
so you don't love it enough, so fuck that.
(cheering)
You can always get another bullshit job.
The grass, man.
That grass is green as shit
on everybody else's lawn.
Indecisiveness, sitting on it,
not doing anything about it,
is just not an option.
The hard work is the most controllable.
Stop asking for permission.
I got shit on for not
being the wine guy anymore
when I started talking about business,
until I did it.
I am stunned by how many
people have the ambition,
and their mouth is running to
what they're gonna accomplish,
and their actions don't map to it at all.
You know, just either gonna
will yourself to victory or not.
Mindset and execution,
clouds and fucking dirt, motherfuckers.
Clouds and dirt.
Make of this here the moment
that you finally make 2018
the year when you start
living your fucking life.
How much do you need?
- Right now, I need 15 grand.
- I'm in.
- I'm sorry, what?
- I'll pay for the whole thing.
- Get the fuck outta here.
Is this tape rolling?
- The problem is, in entrepreneurship,
especially modern day entrepreneurship,
we do not celebrate the game.
We're putting the riches on a pedestal.
I don't think people have really audited
how much down time they
have if they want it.
I'm tired.
What happens when you
stay curious and humble
is you start listening.
When you start listening and executing,
it allows you to have the
audacity to start talking.
That is a good strategy.
I feel when I lose or
things don't go my way
that I truly deserve it.
If I'm gonna enjoy the
fruits of the victories,
I have to learn from the
things that I fucked up on,
'cause you have to respect the game
more than you respect yourself.
I sit here and I say "nothing to lose,"
and the person watching on
YouTube right now is like,
"What the fuck's he talking about?
"He has so much stuff."
I don't have anything to lose
'cause the stuff is not
what I'm playing for.
People get too fancy.
They buy an expensive
car and a second home,
and now they're stuck,
'cause they have a mortgage,
and they have to pay for those things.
I don't say this stuff in theory.
This is not theory for me,
this is not intellectual.
This is practical reality.
Everybody talks about content, right?
What content, what content, what content?
Nobody's talking about community.
It's about the other person, man.
Run the marathon, not the sprint.
I realize what's going on here.
One life.
I realize that I'm living like
this is our only at bat,
and most of you aren't.
Everybody's just like, trying
to close on the first move,
and it never works, not in the long term.
Negativity and tactics
win in the short term.
Positivity and merit and
mistake win in the long term.
You're just not patient.
Like, if you're feeling any angst,
it's because you don't love the process
more than the results.
You're thinking about
$10,000 a month in Ad Sense
instead of loving the fucking dirt.
Like, once you let the math
take over the art, you're dead.
Like, the soul has to come first.
You have to be thoughtful.
You can't just throw it
up there and be like, ugh.
But if it ever trumps the soul, you lose.
This becomes available
when you become great
at something like this.
The problem for everybody right here
is they're trying to do all this
before they got great at this.
Patience.
- Yeah, patience, literally.
- Fucking patience.
Well then, all of a sudden,
all the bullshit that comes along with it
makes a hell of a lot more sense.
Everybody just thinks
they're entitled to it.
It's about leaving money on the table
in the short term, my friend.
The biggest problem is so many of you
sell shit you don't believe in.
You're just doing it
for the fucking money.
You're gonna fucking lose,
and that I don't like.
I think that people don't understand
how much they're gonna
regret when they're older.
Are you self-aware enough
of what kind of founder
or entrepreneur are you?
I don't like when people think
I'm a futurist or disrupter.
I don't think I am.
I actually think all I am
is just very practical.
And do you know how to surround yourself
with the things that you
need to be successful,
instead of blindly thinking
you can do everything?
Just very grateful for
the life that I'm living,
and more importantly, for the attention
that you guys give me,
and so I hope you have a wonderful day.
This shit's binary.
Either you're a good
person or a bad person,
either you've got talent or you don't.
If you're a good person,
you got talent, you win.
If you're the other part, you've lost.
Everybody is trying to mitigate risk
and hedge against vulnerabilities.
I run into them.
I run right the fuck into them.
Bye, guys!
There's a level of binary,
it's truth or it's not,
in hip-hop that I'm obsessed with.
Fucking do the right thing.
Everybody's worried about themselves.
The best way to worry about yourselves
is to do for other people.
Shane, I'm gonna fly you to
New York City, to VaynerMedia,
and you're gonna spend a
day with me and my team,
and we'll show you what works.
(cheering)
But I promise you this,
it's practical as fuck.
The world don't lie.
Everything I say is gonna
happen to me happens.
Let's go.
High, low, fuck the middle.
That's what it is though.
The middle is where everybody's losing.
Slow it down, pick one, do it for a year,
and then adjust.
Like, that's where everybody's losing.
There's just nothing like the beginning
of building a fucking monster.
If you don't love it for the loving it,
and it's about the money, you've lost.
I wanna build the biggest
building in town ever
by just building the
biggest building in town,
while I think most people try to tear down
everybody else's building.
So, I think positivity and good
is practical advice to building an empire.
If you got it like that.
- You gotta go.
- [Gary] You gotta go.
I feel like I'm open
source entrepreneurship.
I'm free, and I'm
putting out my best shit.
Just fuck it, I'm like yes,
and I can leave and go
fucking fly to LA right now,
because the next three hours is yes.
You can't stop winners
from winning, my friends,
and then you can educate the other 99%
and get all the admiration,
and leave a wonderful legacy,
and live a fulfilled life.
That's the model.
It should be.
Doing the right thing is
always the right thing,
always and forever.
Nobody is putting on marathon sneakers.
Everybody wants to be a sprinter.
Everybody wants it tomorrow.
It's the grind, it's the message,
it's doing the right thing.
Embrace the chip on your shoulder,
and expand on it, and triple down on it,
and really use it to your advantage.
- Be willing to work
harder than the next guy,
take more pain than the next person,
and just don't stop.
- Eat shit.
- And don't quit.
That's it, and if you're not doing that,
you're gonna finish second or third.
- It's wen you're in your fucking zone,
when you're doing your thing,
you're not scared of anything.
Even being in the middle of the road,
just walking at it, you're
just not fucking scared.
I'm just feeling great, and I wish you
the ability to be in your fucking zone.
Our ambition to be great is
driving this whole thing.
Where it just clicks, you
understand all the variables,
you know all the moves.
It's the reps.
You've seen it before,
you've seen it before,
you've seen it before.
That's where I'm at, that's
where I'm fucking at.
Rebecca, thank you, she's
done a great interview.
- Thank you for having us.
- You guys will see it.
You're welcome.
Episode 400, I hope you enjoyed it.
Just put this in my face and
wanted me to close it out.
I don't have anything to say.
I'll see you in episode 500.
♪ It's showtime ♪
♪ Ready or not now, it's coming ♪
♪ Imma get mine ♪